i'm in serious trouble
but for now i was free
it took me a long time
some hard lessons to learn what i know
about chasing redemption
i was a wanted man with the price on my
head
but for now i was free
i was on the run with no home and no
country
bombay was a place where everyone
started new
[Music]
look out
you're lucky i was here maybe in my
guardian angel definitely not there's
too much they wanted me for that
[Music]
what brings you to bombay lynn
nothing he'll have secrets
i'll show you mine if you show me yours
i'm number one guy in bombay thank you
but no yes sir
but only after three knows it is a true
know
this is sagarwada my home
this place is not working without
everyone helping each other
why do you have been sagarawada i know
what i did what i need to pay for
we still find a way to balance our bad
for a man who doesn't want trouble you
keep interest in company
when i ask something of you you will do
it
or this place will
burn everyone here is running away from
something
it doesn't work trust me
i'm in serious trouble i'm not going
back empty-handed
you should have gone when you had the
chance
you can be free of anything but yourself
i guess i need to be running towards
something
not away from it
[Music]
you